good afternoon I'm ray well I'm a
product manager on the Google cloud and
I'm JJ I'm an engineer on the cloud
platform so in the last couple of
sessions you have heard about how to
design and build application the app is
build it's ready if you go and now what
that's the topic we're going to cover in
the next hour how to deploy and operate
application on Google Cloud we're going
to look at how to deploy changes
reparations monitor application and
leverage Google Cloud SDK and CLI tools
click great so this is where technology
doesn't always work so first let's talk
about deployment deployment is when your
application goes from a bunch of code
configs binaries to the product that
your customers can actually use you
don't just do it once it happens every
time you shipping a change deployment is
the lifeblood for your plication we're
going to rely to quickie a Google
engineer Brad slackin track these teams
happiness and motivation levels while
building the application on App Engine
his tracking data showed that deployment
is highly correlated to his team's
morale the three highest points during a
development lifecycle happens when you
first commit a code and then when
staging is deployed the app is almost
looking real and then finally when the
release hits production and the product
is being launched so you would say
deployment is great thing right it makes
developers happy and what makes
developers happy tends to be pretty
awesome but for those of us who do it
day in and day out we also know it can
be hard here are some common problems
that you might have faced first you want
to make sure your deployment is is
repeatable and predictable you don't
want well enough tweaks are unique
snowflakes because
chances are at some point you're going
to forget to do them especially under
stress and that can cause failures or
even downtime and downtown you really
don't want to have that but let's face
it every time you're changing your
system there's always a chance of
shipping the bag that can bring down our
site so you want to make sure that we
found early and an impact is contained
to the smallest possible scope
troubleshooting recovering from these
issues also need to be easier now
deployment isn't just about moving a
bunch of binaries to some VMS right we
all know there are a lot other
activities that tend to accompany
deployment for example your release
workflow can include build and test and
during deployment you may need to do
things like start switching data
migration network configuration and our
of them need to come back to being
repeatable and without causing damn time
so now let's look at how to solve these
hard problems on google cloud to achieve
a great department experience JJ cool so
i'm just going to talk a little bit
about some of the things you probably
have already seen a little bit of today
in the previous demo for example so i
have a couple examples here with App
Engine for those of you aren't familiar
with this it was mentioned in the last
less presentation we have this whole
components update app thing that's sort
of a precursor to running the next
command which is g-cloud preview app now
you'll notice one of the commands is
bolded which hopefully is pretty obvious
and you saw that in action a bunch of
times I want to make this kind of the
draw attention to the fact that it's one
command to do a simple take my code and
push it to a live production server when
you know we were deploying in the old
days when we were a start-up it wasn't
exactly the same as just running one
command you usually have a lot of
scripts everything's very very
complicated and having this here means
you can make it repeatable and
automatable which means you can hook it
into a build system you can put it into
a script you can do all sorts of things
with it at the bottom here it doesn't
just stop at this magical g-cloud
command there's more to this so you see
these two again their precursors g-cloud
off log in I think you saw that before
we mentioned that it does sort of this
Oh auth to song and dance to make sure
you are who you say you are the next
step is this in it and then a project
name which configures your local
environment and gets things
set up and I'll talk a little bit more
about that later and the last thing is
get push origin master now at first look
you think okay well I'm pushing to
source control what's actually happening
under the hood here is we set up a git
repository on Google servers and
whenever you push to it it treats it
like production which means that your
code is actually being pushed the same
way it would be with this deploy command
and so we're really trying to embrace
the tools that everybody already knows I
think most people here are probably
familiar with get in some level and what
this does is it lets you use tools that
you already know to do the deployments
that you might not be as familiar with
so the thing to keep note of here is
just because you can deploy your code
doesn't mean you should always just push
it immediately to production I think
there's probably people who do that but
in general as you grow you want more of
an organized way of taking your code
pushing it to the live production
machines and having it be tested and you
know know that your your builds worked
for example in Francesca example before
we noticed he had a build process that
failed a couple of times because of
typos if you would just pushed your code
and then hoped everything work that
wouldn't be so great you would have
downtime so what we have here is release
pipelines which is in preview right now
aur bata bata bata yeah so what this
does is it actually listens on that same
hook that you have for your git
repository and it's going to look
through and monitor for these things now
it has a three-stage process you can see
there's build test and deploy and what's
happening at each step is it's using
Jenkins under the hood and I'm sure
plenty of people are familiar with
Jenkins but under the hood it's running
the full build so for Java or go write
Python you don't necessarily have a
build step but for Java or go it's going
to do the compilation make sure you
don't have any syntax errors or other
compilation time errors then it's going
to run all your unit tests and hopefully
you have some unit tests and then
finally it's going to do the actual
deployment which is what you'd get if
you ran g-cloud preview app deploy and
you can see this last example here you
had a failure on deployment but you're
able to go back and actually say try it
again something must have gone wrong
everything seemed to work and what this
lets you do is make your deployments
automatable and repeatable and easy to
manage because as you know we just
learned that deployment is one of those
most exciting parts of writing software
but it really can be a huge bummer if
you try to deploy and everything falls
apart it's one of those things that we
just
want to see how so this let helps you
make sure you don't do that by
integrating Jenkins and all the other
tools you probably know maven and etc so
that's a pension the platform as a
service Wes talked about this as a
continuum you saw kind of using a hybrid
of these things in the last example with
red s on compute engine and then App
Engine for your sort of web hook serving
with go but what about compute engine so
you saw examples of clicking that ssh
button to pull up in a window that's a
great tool but how exactly can you
repeat that clicking a button is not one
of those automatable tasks g-cloud
compute ssh is the simple command that
drops you into the terminal again this
is the ssh and a browser window but you
could pull this up on your local linux
environment that at that point you can
actually do things like apt-get install
you can if you put a dash y in here you
don't have to actually hit the s key
when you're installing right but this
lets you do more repeatable things you
can put this into scripts you can pass a
command as well you can say what
container do you want to use a different
user which instance you're trying to
talk to all these things and it if you
take out the g-cloud compute it kind of
feels a little bit like you're just
running regular SSH and so everything
you could do with ssh and script you can
do with this but that's not always the
case we all saw that francese had this
you know new instance shell command and
it was a big blob of stuff that
hopefully you didn't all try to write
down but say you want to turn on
something specific when you are starting
a new machine so in this case francese
was turning on I think it was 20 or so
reticent senses he had to write a
special script to do that and then he
used a snapshot image but say you don't
have a snapshot yet or you're not sure
if you want a snapshot there's other
options you can use this whole startup
script idea now the point here is you're
able to turn on a new instance we're
calling it simple Redis right here and
then you can say I wrote on the shell
script that I want you to run whenever
this machine turns on and so in that
case this one happens to be installing
Redis which is exactly what we want and
it can go through the whole song and
dance to turn things on which means
everything suddenly becomes much more
automatable much more repeatable and you
can write scripts that rely on this type
of thing so back to App Engine we don't
always want to deploy everything
immediately imagine you have a huge
change that you're not sure how it's
going to work in production so App
Engine comes with this concept of
versions and it's been around for a
really long time but it's not always
sort of brought to the surface so I just
want to give a quick demo and explain
what this is so versions are the ability
to have different copies of your code
that might be slightly different let's
say in this case the abellana app has a
new way of showing pictures and you fix
a problem where old pictures are showing
up you're not sure if it works and so
you can do is deploy a new version and
then these two pieces of code can run
simultaneously next to each other
depending on the domain that you put in
so its version your app appspot com now
what this means is new versions that you
have that or it might be experimental or
something new that you're trying to
explore and see if it works with your
users you can deploy that concurrently
and then try it on this new URL or you
can use this concept of traffic
splitting where you send part of the
traffic to one version of the app and
part to the other version anybody who's
familiar with a be testing is probably
understand what I'm talking about but
anyone who is familiar with a/b testing
also knows that the infrastructure and
tooling around a/b testing is not always
as great as you want it's it's kind of
frustrating and it takes a lot of time
and investment and so we're trying to do
here is make it so that you're able to
use traffic splitting without spending
six engineering months to build the
tooling to do it so this is the screen
I'm going to show you a demo in a second
go back real quick yeah so this is the
screen when you're turning this on I'll
show you the demo in a second but what
we have here is there's two ways of
splitting traffic one is based on your
IP address so the idea that depending
the IP that you come from it splits
based on that the other is a cookie and
that's more random if you have a big
office environment that I'll share the
same IP coming out you want to use a
cookie so for my demo use a cookie since
we're all in the same room and then you
see here you can choose the amount of
traffic you want to send to a version
and then it's not as prominent here but
it says route the remaining ninety
percent of traffic to the default
version there's always this verdict
concept of a default version so let's do
a quick demo um there's a QR code here
if you guys have a phone i'm actually
going to try this too you can scan this
or go to traffic split appspot com so it
brings up that URL and then if you load
it up it should be one of two colors for
now you should all see it be blue
and then I'm going to pull up and show
you how we can actually do some live
traffic splitting so here is the two
versions you all see blue is the default
so if you loaded it up you'll see blue
on your screen I'm gonna let you guess
what red does pretty straightforward but
what we'll do here is we're going to do
another split and I'm going to change
this to say let's do fifty percent of
the traffic should go to version red and
we're going to route the remaining fifty
percent of traffic to blue we're going
to turn this on and then it gives us a
second and let's see it says it's on now
so if you want to refresh the page some
of you should start getting red and some
should start getting blue and for
example let's see here i still have blue
does anybody have oh there's red red oh
wow look at that about fifty percent of
the room weird so what we have here is
the tooling is all built in wait this
means that you don't have to go and
build your own infrastructure to do this
a/b testing now this example of red and
blue like you would never use this exact
example it's just for a demonstration
right but imagine that you've built a
new machine learning algorithm in
abellana where you change the timeline
depending on who's doing what you decide
that you're going to show pictures from
friends of friends and see if more
people start liking them or start doing
more follow requests or whatever it is
what you can actually do this on an API
level where you keep the app exactly the
same the Android app and the API when it
in that get images thing that Francesca
wrote could return different stuff and
then you'd have two different versions
running concurrently and you'd shift
maybe five or ten percent of traffic to
that new version which sends different
images now what that means is you can
actually test out how things work and
understand if there's any huge
improvement or if you're really just
wasting your time and should roll back
the other thing is performance
improvements say that blue was really
really fast and red was much slower I'd
found I'd find out quickly because I'm
shifting it to only a subset of users
and set up to everybody and so you're
able to do this without experiencing
lots of Valentine so oops got to go back
here and present and now ray is back
ok now let's let me tell you if you
start a few customer stories about how
some DCP customers have made use of the
tools and best practices that JD just
told us about street calm is a CRM site
built an app engine with a peak traffic
of 1500 QPS streak has a very agile
deployment process deploying 5 to 10
times a day they run the integration
tests on test farm on GC before
gradually rolling out the new
deployments now the way they roll out
the department's is using the same
traffic split tool that you just saw JJ
demo first they stand up a new version
of the front end then they send one
percent of traffic there over time the
increase it to three percent five
percent ten percent and eventually to
one hundred percent that's when the
deployment completes when attached with
streaks engineering team they told me
that they have greatly benefited from
practice of continuous integration and
deployment when you release frequently
every deployment is small which reduces
a risk and makes troubleshooting a lot
easier in a rare cases when street
Ranger bug during deployment because the
change is small the impact is usually
fairly mild and because the change is
small the engineers can quickly fig
figure out the culprit code make a fix
and roll forward let's look at another
customer we all know about this one and
snapchat everyday snapchatting avo's
millions of sharings of photos videos
and stories you might remember some of
the recent story releases such as the
electric daisy carnival austin city
limits music festival every time when
new story gets released it is delivered
to the inbox of a huge number of users
resulting massive traffic spikes
snapchat rolls are these changes by
gradually shifting traffic to the new
version over a period of a few hours
snapchats team also regularly uses
traffic split to tune performance
improvements to make the appt faster and
smoother for users we mentioned that
there often other activities that go
along with the deployments let's look at
them in more details let's take the
example of the app abellana if you are
to roll out a major
upgrade to a B'Elanna what you might do
is to stand up the neutronium first and
then update your data structure upgrade
the binaries on VMS recycle them reboot
them and then start switching traffic to
the brand new from the end you want to
make sure these activities can be
sequencing a way that are that's
repeatable and predictable and to solve
these are castration problems the open
source of the open source configuration
management stacks such as prepared chef
and Sybil and salt are commonly used
google cloud has contributed to these
communities plugins templates
documentation and demos to make the
integrations a great experience let's
take puppet as an example what you see
here is the GC compute Mario in puppet
it contains the result type definitions
that describe the configurations of
compute engine resources and this allows
compute engine resources to be modeled
as native papillote IDEs so you can see
here both the raw resources thinks
you're familiar with such as instances
and disks as well as the management
objects like network configurations or
target pool configurations let's look at
how this is used to deploy a real world
app so when our puppet labs is all apps
Pappy forge is in fact deployed on
compute engine using the puppy
integration that you just heard about
now as some of you might know Papa forge
is a platform where siblings and
developers can share and collaborate on
infrastructures code in papist
domain-specific language 900
organization sending videos have
contributed over 2,500 Mario's so far
and every month it's visited by over
35,000 developers so the diagram you see
here is the dependency graph that allows
puppet to figure out how to sequence the
deployment activities for the forge
application if the end state is to have
these VMs at a bottom deployed then this
graft house puppet first you have to go
and configure the things about them
including the firewall configurations
health check and forwarding rules this
allows prepared to be able to automate
and
sequence of deployment activities using
the automated deployment process the
forge team is able to stand up and brand
new version of the forge improv urging
students in less than hour on compute
engine and with that they go to deploy
usually several times a week or
sometimes even multiple times a day so
let's say now your app is has been
successfully deployed it's happening
with the latest and greatest are the
features that you have created next you
want to make sure that your app is
monitored and stays healthy and any
anomalies are brought to attention right
away so let's look at it the monitoring
experience and Google Cloud cool so just
like Ray said monitoring is incredibly
important I think we kind of
underestimate it generally the app is
deployed if it doesn't work you need to
know about it it's one of those things
that we in the most engineers I know me
included tend to forget we think about
all about the coding part and less about
the operations and production part so
there's a few things that are pretty
complicated and I can totally attest
that these are were complicated in the
past for me so first of all set up what
I mean by this is just the ability to
see how many requests per second your
cert web servers handling right off the
bat that's not a simple thing to do
right understanding this there's a lot
of services out there too you can use
graphite for example kenai oh there's a
bunch of interesting metric tracking
services but just keeping track of them
is its work it's something you have to
actually do they don't usually get it
just for free after that let's say that
you have all this data it's usually not
from one place typically there's maybe
five six dozens who knows how many
places we all have data stored is
probably a bunch we need to get this all
in one place that we can actually do
real work with it and that's that's not
always an easy task either hopefully
it's a little easier than the original
setup but lastly this idea of insight
having data is very different than
having knowledge raw data is useful only
if you're able to get something out of
it and so having all the data in the
world and no ability to query it no idea
what it means it becomes absolutely
useless and then it just shows up as a
bill on your bigquery bill or your cloud
storage bill
and that's never fun so these are the
complicated parts how do we actually fix
this there's a few ways and ray and I
are going to talk about a couple of
these and you've seen these a little bit
in the previous demos so first of all
the dashboard I think we kind of
scrolled right past this and all the
previous demos it's been around forever
but it's one of those things where it
gives you something for nothing
effectively if you're running an app
engine app you can see all the requests
per second for example and lots of other
stats and we're actually going to pull
up the stats for that Avalanna app I
hope it's the live one but we'll see so
this is I'm just going to refresh you
can see this is slightly different app
ID I'm not sure if this is the
production one or not we'll see in a
second but we're going to see here is
the dashboard that i just showed before
but it's actually going to be real so
here is the summary this is talking
about requests per second not a whole
lot but this is just the last hour we
can zoom in or zoom out here and see in
the last day and as you can guess these
are spikes from you know about 1pm when
we started sharing the link for the
thing and everybody installed it you can
also see things like latency how many
people off the bat immediately get for
free how late in your application is
it's not a common thing it's kind of
awesome to have what you see here is you
know there was a great time where these
were all zero and then you have some
spikes here if you stretch it out over
the week you'll typically see some very
high latency when we were probably
testing and then everything dropped down
to you know triple digits over the last
two days you can see some interesting
stats here and how it spread out over
time but what's interesting is you get
all these stats basically for free it's
not an easy thing and the bigger your
system is the more complicated it
becomes prior to being at Google I came
through an acquisition back in 2010 and
we were serving about 800,000 QPS on
Amazon so we were Google's biggest
spender on Amazon about a million
dollars a month and with all those
machines collecting all the data we
needed a cluster of about a hundred
graphite machines just to measure that
800,000 per second it was not an easy
task to do and if we have been using a
pension we probably wouldn't have had to
do that and that's 80 machines we would
have just gotten for free in addition to
this you can see traffic utilization the
number of instances you can see how App
Engine scales you up and down over time
right you can see in general we
typically have about one instance
and sometimes peek up to three and
there's little bits here we might be
somewhere in the middle which means for
that time period you had one turn on or
off and what this means is you can see
exactly how you're scaling up and down
so ray is going to talk a little bit now
about the logs viewer yeah so it's jason
as JJ said one of the other province you
have is having too many data sources
well let's face it you've got laws and
metrics from every computing students
and it can be easily hundreds of them
not only that you mouse will be using
different resource types or even
different cloud products aggregating and
correlating are these data can be really
hard let's look how to do that on google
cloud what you see here is the app
engines logs viewer you also saw in the
previous session that's where you look
at all the operations and requests log
for our pension it aggregates are these
large from across our of your instances
together you can view them together in
near real time not only that you can
also do search and filter in this allows
to narrow down to the specific event you
looking for regardless of where it is
generated so let's switch to demo here
this is this is an app that i play with
in my spare time and as you can see here
you can filter by different modules
versions different love levels timeframe
and you can search by specific
attributes such as protocol or status or
you can search by regular expression so
let's say I care about are the error
events in my house because the price
stuff I need to fix so let me look under
the arrow events and I see a few of them
and what I'm going to do is to expand
them to see if I can get more clue on
how to fix them you can see that the
entire cost dark is captured here in the
last viewer for you and not only that
notice there a couple of very special
lines so next to the methods that I to
wrote myself you can see a file name and
a line number and not only that it's
blue and it's underscored so it's
probably clickable where do you think it
takes us to
well so we have landed on the exact line
of code that was responsible for
producing the exception that you saw in
the logs so now you no longer need to go
a noble multiple log files the code
files try to make sense switching back
and forth between them we have just made
love to such linking simpler for you so
Google Cloud also integrates with
third-party monitoring solutions to make
it easy for you to monitor all aspects
applications house and next I'm going to
welcome on stage the engineers from data
they were team out to share their
stories hey guys come on mate from data
dot I'm just going to talk about what we
do so what we do is SAS based monitoring
and will monitor your cloud applications
there are a lot of themes around
dynamically dynamically scaling
applications lots of components and
applications and all of this needs
monitoring and that monitoring is you
can set it up yourself like JJ was
talking about but graphite or whatever
else it takes a lot of time and effort
and we make that super super simple for
you so all the way from languages to
data stores to web tier 2 infrastructure
will monitor it all for you inside of
data doc I'm going to show you a demo as
well on how we do it so not only that
will also capture change events within
your application so for example if
you're using configuration management
tools or deployment tools will gather
changes from there and bring them in
context with your performance metrics so
you can see right after deployment of
performance of your application changes
you can see it right there and then
we'll take all that data and let you
build graphs and let you also use your
favorite chat tools to chat with your
teams to collaborate over these metrics
and performance and talk about them so
here you see a screenshot of people
chatting about stuff over over I think
that's slack
and now I'll jump into the demo and I
wasn't even I wasn't brave enough to try
live demos so I've set it up with with a
video so here you can just go to datacom
sign up with your Google authentication
select that you're a Google App Engine
user fill out a very simple survey form
optionally and then go to next and we'll
bring you up to a panel where it will
ask you to configure your application
for data dog monitoring now here you'll
see it's very straightforward first
thing you do is you clone our data
Doggett module next you add a handler
for data dog inside of your application
in the llamo file next you set up an API
key so we we know where to get the data
from and then you set up the data dog
endpoint URL which matches the handler
basically so our crawlers will go out
and start gathering metrics from data
dog and bring them back into into our
interface and that's it you're done you
can will now start gathering all of the
same metrics that JJ was showing earlier
and bring them back into data dog you
can also configure all these other
things and I'm not going to go into any
of them but you can configure all these
other components that you may be using
inside if your application to monitor
all of those as well here I'm going to
show you how to create a dashboard so
this is just a basic time series
dashboard so we're setting it up and
here i create a time series when i drop
down the list you'll see all of the GAE
metrics in there you'll see all the
metrics from all the other sources as
well so if you're using google compute
engine and you're sending metrics from
there they'll also show up in here so
you select that all the metadata
associated with the metrics so for
example here the project name I can I
can select the project name here as well
and I can add as many metrics as I
I I want some getting the memcache hits
and misses and I'm graphing them and
that's it it's the metrics are done here
I'm adding another graph and let's take
requests latency maybe and then here one
of the things JD was talking about
earlier is versioning of your
application so so one thing stair dog
does really well is it'll take metadata
such as application versions project
names etc and it lets you graph
performance of those things
automatically rolled up by those tags so
for example here I can say tick the tick
the latency and show it to me by version
ID so if you have two versions I can see
the latency of both versions graft in
real time simultaneously and that's
pretty much it so you you have it set up
for data dog and let's go back to the
slides
so you can just for the Google Google
App Engine and Google cloud platform
users we have a free version available
now so you can set up up to 10 projects
plus 5 GC instances for free and if you
need more there's a free trial available
you can set up a limited number of
servers here in this trial and yeah you
can check us out next up is ryan from
berk eva who uses us and GAE and he's
going to talk a little bit more thank
you so i'm ryan bottom i'm the
production systems manager for work eva
where keep it is a cloud-based in a data
analytics company we've got over sixty
percent of the fortune 500 using our w
desk platform to make complex reporting
easy i'm here just to give you a quick
walkthrough on how we're using w desk
and i'm sorry how are you saying data
dog and app engine together so you know
the thing we really love about App
Engine is it gives us the ability to
focus on building our platform making it
better and that's the great thing about
data dog as well as it lets us focus on
that and not on having that large
scaling infrastructure of stats d and
graphite and all the other things you
need to do this so what are we currently
monitoring we've got 40 different app
and app spots or monitoring with about
280 modules or monitoring our
infrastructure over the last week is
what you're seeing here is the system is
instance count we've scaled anywhere
from a couple hundred instances to over
4,000 instances during that week and
back down and the nice thing is data dog
skills right alongside that to handle
that all those metrics coming up
so what's this really look like what
we've got here is we're taking data from
multiple sources we're using a custom
Python application that we're in that's
using the cloud monitoring API from
google to grab data from App Engine data
from compute engine instances we're
correlating data from bigquery our
splunk logs or even taking some events
from our own internal deployment tool
push them all up via data dogs REST API
and what you're seeing here is a just
noted that stream of everything that's
happened on a particular app spot so
what's this really look like this is one
of our this is a part of one of our
dashboards that we use so what you're
seeing here is latency traffic instance
counts status codes responses you're
also seeing URL response times that
we're setting up outside of the cloud
monitoring API we're also in the event
stream there you'll notice the deploy
that's happened we're able to correlate
this you're seeing these are two
different modules default and big sky f1
these are two modules we have on our
application so this is a really great
way to correlate data from lots of data
points across your platform and get a
really quick view into it the nice thing
is you know we take all these data we
push it up the data dog we set up alerts
there that can then send notifications
out to our operations team our
developers our customer service teams as
needed and I hope because it like that
real quick view and vector array Thank
You Ryan Amit
so you want to get your monitoring data
in real time so you can know exactly
what's going on right now and one needs
your attention but the same time you
also need to be able to look across a
period of time and draw insights from
history and analysis and here are some
examples to do analysis on the App
Engine logs that you just saw you can
export them into bigquery now bigquery
is Google clouds clouds big data
platform that can process fast queries
over Marco terabytes of data you're
going to hear all about it in the next
session optimize and analyze money is
important right so billing and cost
another very important aspect of
application to monitor a developer
console they just saw would show you
your current spending as well as monthly
history if you want to run any deeper
analysis on your casting then you can
use the billing export and computer
usage export to save the more granular
data into your designated Google Cloud
Storage bucket the file you're seeing
here is a JSON file that comes around
the billing export issues you are
important attributes of your cost
structure such as your project number
measurements timeframe and resource type
wizard file you can now import it into a
spreadsheet or you can write a script to
crunch the numbers and you can use also
additional cost optimization tools for
application so one example of such a
tall going to see here is clouding
clouding monitors and analyzes a Google
deploying google cloud deployments and
gives you visibility into your usage
performance and cost it then translates
this data into insights and actionable
recommendations on how to optimize your
cloud deployments reduce costs and
maximize your cloud ROI and the
screenshot is seeing here is the
crowding council combining the usage
export with real monitoring data it
shows the cost of a google cloud
application with daily resolution
trending over weeks and months you can
also break down the cost by
different services different instance
types are from business perspective by
projects campaigns or business units so
so far we have looked at a number of you
I tools that are useful to you but I
also know for many of you in your
day-to-day job command line is a
preferred mode of working so next JD is
going to have to us about the SDK and
command-line tools right so some of this
stuff is going to seem you know you've
seen it before in previous demos I just
want to call attention to a few things
and maybe explain a little bit about
what we're going for with the CLI and
the command line interface for cloud
platform so there's a few targets that
we're really aiming for 11 is
installation and updating right now
we're focusing on a single line install
if you go to cloud google com / sdk it's
a copy and paste it's a one liner and
we're hoping to make that even easier
with a natural posit ori and all that
that's on the on the docket there's also
this idea of a component manager you
know it's a we update or fix some bugs
say we add a new service I think you saw
as before and that g-cloud components
update app that was sort of the
precursor I mentioned this is the
component manager in action it's it's
letting you say I want to install a new
piece with g-cloud here's the new things
that are available you'll also notice
that if you run a command using say
g-cloud compute and there's a new
version available you get an automatic
prompt that says do you want to update
to the latest version we fixed bugs x
y&z you just hit Y and everything will
sort of magically work and this is one
of those things that you know I think
they're really important it helps us
make sure that the code running on your
machine is you know actively the newest
version and then you also noticed this
environment setup what I talked about
before with that whole git push that
just sort of magically works this get
Nagi cloud in it command is the thing
that really makes that all happen it
sets up your local environment with the
proper authentication and configuration
options so these things sort of just
work out of the box you shouldn't really
have to worry about them there's no
generate an ssh key and all the entropy
needed then copying that somewhere then
doing all this work it just sort of
happens in addition to all this we want
it to be relatively easy to learn and
use what that means is auto completion
has to work and kind of lazy at the
command line and there's for example and
get
there's plenty of commands that I forget
the order of things or if I've typed in
our I want rebase to finish with gclub
you get the same sort of thing if you
hit tab tab when you're halfway done
you'll get either the options that match
or it'll auto complete all the way
through exactly like sort of a
first-class citizen in the linux world
another thing is help text I don't want
to open up a web page every time I don't
know what a command does or how to use
it or all the details behind it the
performance implications the examples
all these things i would want right away
and in the linux world i type man to get
the man page if you use g-cloud double
dash help or in some cases just help
alone what happens is you end up seeing
a man style help text that explains all
the details of how to use the command
just like I said with with performance
implications examples and all the other
details and we're actively adding more
and more to these to make sure that
they're concise but still descriptive
lastly syntax and this ties into this
last piece as well so i'll talk about
that together i don't know if anybody
remembers in the old days when there was
gcutil for compute engine and then
g-cloud for other things what we're
really trying to do is consolidate these
into one tool so you don't have to
install a bunch of different things to
do this and on the docket still we have
to add G cloud storage that's that's
coming up but what we're trying to do
here is make it so everything's very
consistent for example in this case you
see g-cloud preview app you'll notice
that preview is going to be our way of
trying out new things that are in beta
that are exposed to everyone but it's
not exactly a public thing we haven't
committed to it yet we don't want you
writing lots of scripts and then being
upset if things change so we put it
under the preview flag otherwise you
have g-cloud sequel g-cloud compute all
the things that sort of just makes sense
you run your g-cloud then pick a service
and then there's lots of commands to
come with that service so app for App
Engine sequel for cloud sequel and I'm
compute for compute engine and there'll
be more and more over time and our goal
here is to really have consistent and
easy-to-understand syntax so that you
don't run into problems where you run a
command and it does the opposite of what
you're expecting it to do or do you find
out that the arguments are out of order
because on the one command it looks like
version a and over here it looks like
version B we really wanted so that all
these things are really easy to
understand
and and that you don't get confused and
tripped up on stupid and frustrating
things so we're really trying to make
that simple so I just want to illustrate
a couple of common tasks here and you've
seen these before in the previous
examples francese presentation actually
covered a bunch of these and I think Wes
covered some of them as well so this
here this is compute instances list I
don't know if you can see that i'm
trying to light it up what this does is
it tells you which compute engine
instances you have running right all
this means is that you're going to see
the list of things the list of machines
the instances that are up in your
account and I've blocked out the IPS
obviously but it gives you all this data
now because it's a regular Linux command
you can pipe it in through less or if
you want to grep for something you can
pipe it through grab it right these are
all just basic linux tools with standard
output and so that means that you can
use cut if you want to just pull out all
the external ip's of your machines right
so you use your regular linux tools here
you have g-cloud dns manager zone list
hoping you can guess what that is a
manager zone is a thing that contains
domains right and so in here you're
seeing a list of JSON output that
basically has all the details of the
domain that you're you have registered
so there should be a bunch of them and
if you have adjacent tool that process
is standard out you can always pipe this
through things like Jay grep or whatever
else you want and then you can filter
through if you want to pull out some
data or pipe it through a Python script
or whatever else might you might want to
do and lastly this is the example I've
mentioned before with the component
manager this idea is I want to be able
to just update everything that's
available so you're on g-cloud
components update and what will happen
is you'll see all these things that may
have been updated since your last run
now keep in mind you'll still get the
auto prompt whenever you run a command
if there's something new because we want
you to have the latest version but this
is your way of saying before I even
start I want to make sure everything's
up to date and so if you were running a
script for example and you want to make
sure you have the latest version you
could just put this at the beginning and
then everything will make sure that you
have the newest version before you go so
that's all we have for today we have a
few minutes left for questions as far as
I know anything is fair game I have a
lot of experience with all this cloud
stuff and ray here is a product manager
so we have tons of things to answer if
if you have anything you're curious
about but thanks for for watching it and
we also want to give you the links to
the open source github projects for the
air for the abellana app that we've
promised so yeah the fuel keep it up so
yeah we'll leave this you I'll write
them down so yeah the first one is the
gcp that's the the server side the go
code and the second one is Avalanna
android that's the android app java code
and so you can look at both of those if
you just go to a github / Google cloud
platform you can browse all of our stuff
so there's plenty of things that are
available there if you're curious about
what we're working on in the open source
world but these are the two from today
one of the biggest challenges with
running multiple versions data
versioning right and the data model
changes what you do what are the best
practices that you follow so I can't
speak to the current version of how
things are just to repeat the question
in case anyone's curious in this idea of
separate versions what happens if you
have separate concepts of like the data
model say you are adding a new field and
in the new version you have the new
field in the old version you don't or if
you have it the other way around you're
removing a field how do you deal with
this across inside cloud datastore thing
yet datastore yeah yeah I mean typically
both no sequel which is flexible schema
and cloud sequel which might have a yeah
so the best practices I mean they're the
standard ones where you're supposed to
take the common denominator there and
make sure that your code can operate in
both environments data changes are not
hugely recommended with separate
versions inside App Engine but you can
still do it and we're actually working
on some really cool stuff for data store
and it should be out somewhere in q2 q3
where the idea is will have an overlay
on top of things and you'll be able to
operate on that and test it and that way
you'll be able to sort of change data
without actually um you know changing
your production data and this is it's
you know we're still working on
timelines we don't know for sure but
it's you know we're trying to address
that problem and another common practice
we've seen here is instead of using the
different versions that you actually use
different projects when you're four
major releases where your data actually
changes enough in the you you don't want
here to stay Stadium data staging code
to actually damage your production data
is to set up different projects and
that's where you get like you know very
separate partitions between the data
versions yeah so separate applications
can fix the problem as well but one of
the other challenges when we come from
the sequel world to the no sequel world
is is writing too many migration scripts
right for example if you have a sequence
sequence script you will just do an
update if you rename a field for example
but if you have to do it on App Engine
cloud cloud datastore you have to do a
whole lot of bad shop so how do you deal
with those kind of situation large
databases I think this is a problem
across a lot of no sequel options not
just data store right instead of having
a concept of a schema and a column you
have a dictionary style of data where to
actually do this look at MongoDB for
example to do this you actually have to
go through an update each item so
there's no easy way to do this except
for kind of deal with the bad column
name it's it's not no great answer for
that but I actually I don't know any
better option so deal with it in code or
what do you look for migrating data
along the way I think the App Engine
best practice is to have it iterate
through each item if you really need to
clean up existing old data and it can be
both cpu intensive and therefore cost
intensive so it's not hugely recommended
but if you really need your data to look
that way that's sort of what you're
gonna have to do all right thank you
sure you talk for a second about
splitting versions and slowly migrating
do we have tools available for checking
say error rates or latency on request a
given URL so that we can more easily
identify when we need to go oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] and roll back versus when we're
happy with the deployment something
that's where for example integrating
with with da da da you can track you
know metrics from different versions and
it set alerts for them so that way you
can able you too you know deploy
something to staging your staging
versions and then the next are switching
traffic and with alerts a monitoring on
your new version if you start seeing
latency you know bump app or error rates
bump app you can get an alert and you
will know to like stop it stop it from
further migrating right roll back the
percentage traffic so you can actually
fix the new version before you raw
deployments again and in the logs were
you like you saw there was that drop
down where you can choose a version and
so if you happen to be watching
particular time you can pick which
version and see all the logs that are
coming through a filter by errors on
version X and then you can see what's
going on but hooking into data dog is
more of the push concept where you can
set alerts on that data elbow and cloud
monitoring yes that also sorry yeah it
has it's a product that we have we're
trying to talk about data dog Jeremy
yeah so cloud monitoring is another tool
that does similar things where you can
alert on these different metrics and is
that in it's in beta now Jeremy early
access so you don't have access to it
today unless you're on the whitelist
down soon it'll be in beta which means
it'll be open to every and if you want
to be added to RT access Jeremy is the
guy in charge if I go talk to him purple
shirt in the back he's leaving now sorry
go ahead oh yeah my question is about
that cloud the bugger you talked in the
keynotes when you talk in the locks part
you can go to the line and with the
problem that's fine but what about you
know the buggin in the production
environment yeah so in the in the other
track upstairs of the next hour the
wrong timing sighs talk is going to you
know talking more details about debugger
and also show you a demo of the debugger
but it's kind of both you know the
largest source link and debugger kind of
follow the you know if you if you deploy
your course or push it apart and we so
we can keep a metadata and understand
what's the version running in production
and how which version of code it relates
to then we can you know do others
linking between between a log and source
code as well set debugging points for
you and if you want to ask more
melodious right here if she knows
everything about cloud debugger read hey
you guys mentioned analyzing logs with
bigquery it's a way to automatically get
your a [ __ ] and long to the bigquery so
in the next session you're gonna look at
look at more details there but also the
functionality to add America explore log
into bigquery it sounds way again Jeremy
is probably the person holding how many
times at hey when you're gonna get it
there's caught her okay it's gonna come
as a Christmas present okay thanks a lot
everybody really appreciate it thank you